[Music]
hello everyone good morning thanks for
thanks for coming to this session
I'm internal Chakraborty I'm a product
guy with Google cloud platform and
together with my colleagues here in this
session we're going to cover three
things one is the key challenges for
edge and Google clouds offering to
address those challenges second is how
do we as Google cloud and Google in
general how do we think how are we
thinking about offering an integrated AI
platform and finally we'll have some
demos for you so let's get started so
let's start with a simple dictionary
definition of Internet of Things by the
way the counter is not working here the
Internet of Things if you look at the
dictionary the definition is
interconnection of computing devices
embedded in everyday things via the
Internet essentially it is little things
connected to the Internet and hence
Internet of Things and in this path of
interconnection they're really three
interacting units there's a you know
network of objects that are either that
connect wired or wirelessly to Internet
and the network of objects could be
devices can be appliances cars and and
so on and so forth then there are
gateways which acts as bridges between
those devices and the Internet and
finally cloud where you want to store
the information which you're receiving
from the devices and gateways for
processing it and then analyzing it to
derive intelligence as you all might
already know that is estimated by 20 end
of 2020 they'll be around 25 billion
such installed
IOT units and and across and these IT
needs would be installed across the
consumer segments as well as the
business segments so that's an enormous
number of devices connected to the
Internet
and we are already generating more data
than ever with these Internet of Things
devices and so as we as and the data
generation is continuing to grow so for
when Google around last year we
announced clarity core to really help
customers enterprise customers and
developers to manage this massive number
of devices and be able to easily ingest
influx of data from these devices so
clarity course is a fully managed
service which allows you to securely
connect and manage your devices on
Google cloud and since their
announcements last year the market
reaction the reaction from our customers
and partner and partners has been really
positive it was it's been phenomenal we
have customers in manufacturing in a
smart parking management healthcare oil
and gas services who are connecting
their assets on the field to Google
chlorotic or so that they can connect
all these devices securely and then use
the rest of our Google Cloud analytics
and AI services for ingesting storing
data and really deriving intelligence
and as we as we started working with
quadratic or our our focus has been on
four critical areas one is intelligence
so once you collected all this data from
the installed units you know what do you
do with those data so we provide we want
to make sure that we make it really easy
for you guys for customers and partners
to derive intelligence from the data
that you collect second is scale so
clarity platform and clarity core is is
a service as a service right so whether
you connect one device or you tend to
connect hundreds of thousands or even
millions of devices you just connect
your devices and we scale internally as
a customer as a developer you don't have
to worry about adding new infrastructure
or adding a new VM instance as you add
more devices so you really have focused
on scale
second third is security we we wanted to
make sure that each
each IOT devices there can be
individually authenticated and it makes
and it makes a secure connection to
Google Cloud and finally we focused on
the building up a robust partner
ecosystem so we've been working really
hard on these four critical areas and we
identified early on that there is an
emergent need for running local services
close to the devices itself to the edge
devices itself and in fact all these
four critical areas are relevant for
edge devices as well and most important
of most important of those four was
intelligence at the edge so let's take
some example use cases and if you have a
camera pointed at your parking lot where
you were you're using the camera to
count real-time the number of cars that
are parked in the in the parking lot it
doesn't really make cost-effective it's
not really cost-effective and doesn't
really make any sense to send every
frame of the video from the camera to
cloud to analyze and count the number of
cars that are there in the parking lot
what if you could just do it in the in
the camera itself if you have a factory
with robots
there could be regulatory reasons there
could be reasons for which you want to
protect your IP and you don't want to
send all the data to Google Cloud you
might want to filter some of the data on
the edge itself if you have if you're
doing object detection using a camera or
some other device that there are for
privacy reasons you may not want to send
all the sensitive data to cloud but you
would want to you would want to run some
of those analysis and intelligence on
the device itself so based on on these
for all these following reasons of right
about before I'm very excited that we
announced two new products for edge
computing at NIH intelligence one is
cloud ith cloud ith is a software stack
which extends the AI and data processing
capabilities of Google cloud to the edge
and second is HTP you
which is a Google design high-performing
hardware chip to run machine learning
inference on the edge device itself so
let's get a little bit more into the
details of these two product so with all
righty edge as I mentioned it's a
software runtime that you can run in
your IOT gateway devices you can write
it on a camera you can run it on any
connected device that has some compute
capabilities essentially a device that
has a CPU and cloud RT edge software
runtime allows you to run machine
learning inference on the edge device
itself it has built-in support for HTTP
you so that you can have lightning fast
machine learning inference on your edge
device itself you know we thought about
edge you can also locally store some of
it your data you can process it you can
do translation you can do some
aggregation and filtration before you
send the data back to cloud Android
things is one of our Google's managed
operating system for IOT devices which
has got a secure boot so it's designed
from ground water ground up for security
and and software software update and
cloud out the edge runs on Android
things and we planning to soon support I
have release have support for Linux
versions as well and it securely
connects your edge devices to Google
Cloud at the same time we've also added
enhance security through Hardware root
of trust and cloud right edge seamlessly
works with Google clarity core and rest
of Google cloud IT platform for
hassle-free provisioning so it's a
complete software stack to run machine
learning inference on the edge device
itself and you know there are there two
key components that enables clarity edge
two for real-time AI on the edge device
itself there's a tensorflow light based
runtime that allows you to run those
machine learning inference on the edge
reducing latency and then
increasing the versatility of your edge
device and because we use tensorflow
light runtime which is an open source
you can you can use cloud IT edge with
edge TPU for really for lightning fast
and high performing performance but if
you have a device which doesn't have an
HTP you or your use case doesn't require
the horsepower of HTTP you chip you can
still run clarity edge and do local
inference on your edge device which just
has which has a GPU or just has a CPU
itself so it's pretty flexible that way
and the second component is IOT core
that securely connects your edge device
to Google Cloud so you can do you can
you can manage your software you can do
software from software and for more
updates you can exchange data and also
exchange machine learning models between
your edge device and the cloud so
combined with these two key components
with clarity edge offers you is a is the
software runtime format for running
machine learning inference but also to
orchestrate your models and data
exchange with Google Cloud let's take an
example say you have a factory with a
high velocity assembly line and you want
to detect anomalies real-time and you
have a camera that has our edge TPU chip
and you have our that as it's running
Android things and as cloud right eh
software runtime running on it and is
you have you have collected historical
data from your assembly line production
which you can then use which using cloud
machine learning engine you can train a
model to accurately detect defects you
can then push down that model to the
camera via our quadratic or and cloud
riding edge software and using HTTP you
now you can do real-time detection of
anomaly on your high velocity assembly
so with clarity edge or as a software an
edge TPU chip as a hardware chip
together with our cloud platform we
really are you can really build an
integrated or a eye solution with our IT
platform
now let's look at edge TPU and to tell
you more about HT PU and their
motivations for its building edge TB
chip let me to invite my friend Olivia
tamam who is the tech lead for HDPE you
in the googly eye team Olivia thanks
Antonio so good morning everyone it's a
real pleasure to be here with you today
to talk about HTTP you and actually what
we want to do is not only to present you
what HTTP you is but we also want to
explain why we have developed HTTP you
at Google and to do that we want to walk
you through the four key motivations
that you see on the slide so the first
motivation that we heard is we want to
bring high quality AI to the edge and
buy high quality I mean high speed and
high accuracy so at Google we are
developing machine learning models for
the edge one of our flagship models for
image classification is mobile net and
it's not the unique features but one of
the nice things about mobile net is that
it's a highly configurable model and you
can easily trade more computations for
more accuracy so just to get an idea of
the relationship between the two let's
look at this graph where you see on the
x-axis the computational cost of running
one inference at the edge expressed in
millions of multiply add x' and on the
y-axis you have the accuracy so if
you're shooting for a moderate amount of
accuracy like 60 percent you're going to
pay 60 million multiply ads that's 120
million operations but if you want to
burn that up to 75 percent accuracy
you're going to have to pay ten times
that cost 1.2 billion operations and
that particular graph stops at 600
million multiply ads you can invest more
computations to get even more accuracy
so the point here is that the
computational cost of high accuracy is
very steep and what we want to do thus
in order to sustain high-quality AI at
the edge
to deliver high performance but because
this is also about embedded applications
we have to do this at a very low cost
and naturally in a small physical and
power footprint and that was basically
the first charter that we had with edge
TPU so the second motivation that we had
relates to what Indrani just explained
we are building an an to an AI
infrastructure cloud to edge AI to
hardware and the key goal is to make it
as easy as possible for our customers to
deploy their AI based solutions by
piggybacking basically this
infrastructure so it involves work
across the three stacks AI software and
hardware naturally and as you all know
we have already been developing a custom
AI hardware solution for the cloud cloud
CPU so by introducing HTTP you the other
thing we wanted to do is to complement
that infrastructure so again to make it
as easy as possible for consumers to
they provide a solution now we think
actually HTTP U is going to bring a lot
of value to our customers in terms of
helping them deploy AI at the edge but
we also are developing an open
infrastructure so we see HTTP you as
only one option that we are making
available to our customers and customers
remain completely free to choose any
hardware solution they want
so the third motivation that we had is
more technical and it relates actually
to a fairly fundamental point about
custom hardware design which is actually
very often overloads a simple one that's
very often often overlooked and it's the
fact that custom hardware design is all
about leveraging in Hardware the
properties of the algorithms so in this
case a AI algorithms so that can be a
challenge for hardware designers because
it means they have to develop a fairly
intimate knowledge of the target
algorithms of AI algorithms so that can
be a challenge for most organizations
but for Google it can also be an
opportunity because all hardware
designers have access to abundant AI
expertise and therefore they can know
what are the latest trends in AI and
that can help them decide what kind of
features they need to bring within their
hardware designs
now that's one advantage of having both
expertise hardware and AI within the
same company but it's not the only one
what we can do and what we are
increasingly doing is that we can also
go the other way around and start
adapting AI algorithms so that they work
as well as possible on the custom AI
hardware and the last point is that
probably one of the biggest
misconceptions about custom AI hardware
is that it's primarily a hardware task
while in fact the biggest difficulty is
the software layer which you use to map
AI algorithms onto the custom hardware
so what we are really striving to do is
to develop a holistic approach across
the three stack and in both as a
conviction but increasingly better on or
experience this is what is going to
yield the best results in terms of
custom AI hardware design or fourth
motivation relates to this one - the one
I just presented so it's not only that
all hardware designers have to have
access to the latest trends in AI but
it's also that AI is evolving extremely
quickly this graph that you see here has
been collected by colleagues at Google
AI and it shows the number of AI related
research articles which have been
submitted to archive over the past
decades and the key message here is that
this curve is exponential has an
exponential basically shape so there is
just underlines the very rapid
progression of AI so that again can be
both a challenge and an opportunity it
is a challenge because as you know the
timeline of hardware is very different
from the timeline of AI research but it
can become an opportunity if we learn to
tackle in hardware this rapid evolution
of AI if we do that then what is going
to happen is that the performance of the
cousteau Mei Hardware again expressed in
speed and accuracy is now going to
progress more or less at the same pace
as that of AI algorithms and as you can
see that's very fast so one way to think
about it is that increasingly AI
algorithms are playing for custom AI
Hardware more or less the same role as
transistor technology is playing for
general proposed architectures and when
we set on to design
in HTTP you from the beginning we had
that objective in mind which is how are
we going to tackle this very rapid
evolution of AI and what we've designed
is actually what we've created is not
just one design but it is a design
approach exactly for that purpose that's
also why when we think about the first
ship that we are presenting today even
though it's achieving a very good
performance per dollar ratio which we
think is going to help disseminate
high-quality AI at the edge we also
think about it only as a first step in a
long journey which is going to be
largely driven by AI and we are already
well underway we were second design and
we've already started to work on the
third design and at every step what we
are going to do basically is to improve
the AI support improved performance and
power and bring more functionalities so
those are some of the key motivations
that we had actually to design at GPU
and now to present you in more details
what we are going to provide rural
customers in the coming month I'm going
to invite AJ who is the hdbo product
manager to present you that thank you
thanks Olivia money everyone I'm a
janitor the product manager for STP use
will go over quickly on what we're
releasing and how users can have access
to what's being announced today so that
is the HTTP you one thing to note here
is that the one-cent that is shown is
indicative of the size of the HDP oh it
does not indicate the cost but in all
seriousness though when we're designing
the HTTP use we were striving to achieve
a very high performance per dollar and
I'm proud to say that we've been able to
achieve that our goals have been met and
we've been able to do that at a
relatively low power footprint and also
physical footprint on how big the HTTP
is and a combination of the high
performance per dollar low-power as well
as the low physical footprint allows
broad deployment of HTTP use in multiple
applications and it helps our goal to
democratize AI in terms of the HTTP you
itself the first generation that is
being announced now and the roadmap is
an inference accelerator and it's the
architecture was optimized for vision
applications of course it's an
accelerator it can be used for multiple
models but it was optimized for vision
it can run concurrent state of and what
what we can do with an accelerator at
the edge is essentially run multiple
state-of-the-art models concurrently for
example on a high resolution video
without losing frame rate right the as
an example of what Olivia mentioned
earlier the moon walnut v2 we can
achieve several hundred inferences per
second on the highest accuracy versions
of those models
so what we're announcing is not just the
hardware though what we are trying to do
is bring the leadership and the
expertise that Google has in hardware
software and AI and combine those into a
solution which customers can have access
to so as internal pointed out earlier we
already talked about the cloud royalty
edge and the HTTP you and how they
interact we are adding components which
make use of our expertise in AI as well
as software so in AI for example we will
be releasing at the time of the product
launch which is in October when early
access customers can have access to this
the product will be releasing a set of
precompiled models these are going to be
compiled to tensorflow light which is
Google's open source AI framework for
the edge intense flow light allows low
latency at a small binary size for your
edge applications we will be announcing
models for example there are mobile net
base models and other architectures as
well and it'll also be integrated with
ml kit ml kit is a beta product that
Google announced a few months ago which
which has an SDK which allows users to
have commonly used AI applications at
the edge and if you have more complex
needs ml kit also provides an API for
you to serve those models onto your edge
devices a next step after that is we
would enable transfer learning on those
pre-compile models that we are going to
be providing so what is transfer
learning transfer learning is a method
where you can repurpose an existing
model which is made for one use case and
customize that based on your own data
sets for your specific use case so
that's a very powerful method and it
really helps because the investment
needed from users in terms of the time
the effort and the expertise in machine
learning is vastly reduced so the
existing precompile models can be Reaper
you can bring your own data and reuse
your data for your specific application
needs in a future update we will also be
releasing the tensorflow Lite compiler
for HTTP use so you can customize you
can start your model design from scratch
we also want to make it easy for
customers to deploy HTTP you at your
applications the idea being we would
like you to be able to envision your use
cases that serve your business needs and
using the products that we are going to
be releasing you can iterate and
prototype you know you use the models in
your hardware applications use the
transfer learning function to optimize
those models for your use case and test
it out in your system and when you're
satisfied with the results you deploy
that in your real applications and we
are also announcing and making available
the HTTP you development kit and there
are two versions of development kit
depending on where you are in the
ecosystem if you want a fully integrated
solution with the HTTP you connected to
an SOC
what we are now saying is a system on
module so what you see here is a system
on module it has the HTTP you ASIC
connects to and a CPU and also a crypto
for security that module connects on to
I'll take a break there the HTTP you is
that is at Red Square that we are seeing
there and this is to scale by the way in
terms of the famous one sent the HTTP
arm connects to a base board and the
base board essentially expands the i/o
connectivity options that are available
so there's a whole slew of connectivity
there that you have USB a port USB C
HDMI there's a meeping interface to
connect your camera onto it it's got a
Wi-Fi interface and Ethernet and a five
volt DC power to power the devices so if
you need a fully integrated solution
this is what you use
the SOC will have Android things
pre-loaded onto it it can connect onto
the internet you can download the
precompile models that we mentioned in
the previous slides and you can run
inference locally it also will have the
IOT edge solution so once you runs
inference locally your application can
decide what to do with the local data
and also use IOT edge to load back the
data as you need back to the cloud for
storage or retrieval or for further
analysis we are also announcing the edge
TPU accelerator
it's a USBC form factor device and if
you have an existing system that has a
host interface available you can just
connect the HTTP you accelerator using
the USB C on to your systems and
accelerate your machine running
workloads so both of these solutions
have been designed internally at Google
with partnership from external vendors
for four different components it's been
designed by the Google aiy team which is
a team within the Google AI business
function alright and to show some
functionality of of the boats and what
we can do with it I'd like to invite
Preston onto the stage Preston is our
head of IOT solutions and he'll help us
showcase what a quick example of what
the HTTP you can do
great so as as I said let's take a look
at some of the performance capabilities
of edge TPU so I'm going to mostly be
off stage and run you through this demo
what we do is we have two systems set up
here one with edge TPU and one without
and so we wanted to show you some of the
performance differences as well as how
you combine the inference on the edge
with sending data to the cloud so give
me one second to start up some things
and actually if I could have you guys
come over here because you are
accidentally actually in camera not as
planned so if you can come over to the
with the other folks on the far other
side so what we've got is um we've got
two cameras set up yeah just you were
your seats were in frame so we've got
we've got two cameras set up and what
we're using our high-resolution cameras
high frame rate cameras these are 1080p
cameras filming at 60 frames per second
and you can see already that if you look
at the top frame that is a system
without the TPU the frames per second in
which we're able to compute and analyze
the video are already down to like 13
frames per second whereas the frames per
second with TPU are still at a very high
frame rate processing of 45 frames per
second now when you're new I was going
to invite my colleague Matt one of the
IOT engineers who helped us with this
demo on stage and so you can see that as
Matt walked on stage we've we've
detected Matt we see him on stage and
you can see that already the frame rates
starting to drop a little bit without
the without the TPU now all of this
inference all the ml that's detecting
Matt on stage is happening entirely on
the edge so we're not able to
realistically stream this kind of high
frame rate high resolution video
directly to the cloud so we need to be
able to compute on this information it's
so rich strictly on the edge but since
we have now some information we're
interested in we can detect essentially
some information about what we're seeing
so one of the things is we can now look
at just a simple metric of how many
things have we detected that we're
interested in the frame and we may
average this out over five seconds
locally on the edge that we have a
simple metric that we can then send to
the cloud and once we're sending
information on the cloud we can start to
visualize it in things like a dashboard
so I have starting out here a very
simple dashboard that I can just see
that we have one one person on stage
right now so but as a few other
colleagues gradually joined Matt
and we increase that number we can start
to look at what that performance is so
in this case we're not only going to
send just the count of people what we're
interested in some more information
about the performance of the actual
system here so I'm gonna switch briefly
to the dashboards for a moment so you
can sort of see what that looks like so
here we're looking at three pieces of
information the top is the number of
objects detected the second graph is the
frame rate and then the third is sort of
a gauge of the instantaneous frame rate
you can see that with edge TPU we're
still holding steady at about 30 frames
per second of effective processing now
this is not just one model running per
frame we're actually running a complex
set of cascading models so we're doing
many inferences per frame to achieve the
information we're interested in and so
as you can see that as the number of of
people in frame goes up the inference
really starts to drop without a TPU and
why does this matter well if you're
looking at something like this very sort
of high frame rate high-resolution video
it does it lets us do a couple things
one is it's letting us detect you know
that there are still people who might be
very small in the frame right so if
you're thinking of looking at say very
small defects on equipment surface
defects or small parts high resolution
allows you to still provide the machine
learning full information and we're not
only using high resolution on the camera
input side we're actually not extremely
down sampling that video to feed to a
model so we're able to feed high
resolution directly into the model
because of the computation power of of
the edge TPU and as these as these
numbers increase you'll continue to see
sort of frame rate dropping on the left
but we want to be able to sort of also
show that why does a frame rate matter
if we're losing
frame's what are we losing so this model
is not only detecting things like the
the person on stage but we're able to
detect a degree of information about
what their orientation is what what
their attention is looking at and we can
count these as essentially glances at
the camera now these are glances that
lasts only a moment and so if we look
now at the way we've counted glances
between these two systems you can see
that many glances are simply missed by
the system without a TP you because
they're so momentary and if you think
about applications of the TPU in places
such as high-speed manufacturing lines
or other places where momentary
information that might exist in an
acoustic signal that will be dropped or
missed these essentially act as as sort
of dropping important events in the
system you're trying to analyze and so
as you as these systems are unable to
keep up you're essentially losing
critical information and again all that
we're interested in on the cloud side
here is these counts and metrics we
don't have a need to sort of send the
complex or potentially sensitive
information that's happening on the edge
directly to the cloud for processing we
can keep that processing happening
strictly on the edge so thank you very
much colleagues and with that I will
return the presentation back to Internet
[Applause]
Thank You Preston so as you can see
Thanks say thanks person so as you can
see wit with HTP you the the number of
inferences and the infants infants you
can do at a high frame rate is much
higher than what you can do without HDPE
you and we've used we've run multiple
models in this demo this models were
internally built within Google just for
the purpose to showcase the capabilities
and the horsepower we have with HDPE you
we don't plan to make it publicly
available but you can use in your your
own model you can train your own model
using cloud machine learning engine and
then use rhtp you do where you need we
have use case for such high processing
you know real-time analysis so you know
we've since as we started working on
this we've been also engaging some of
our early customers and and the feedback
from this customers has been really
positive
LG CNS for example has has used a cloud
machine learning engine and our HT PU
and clarity edge on some of their
cameras to really improve the
productivity by detecting defects in
their hive high fast assembly line
real-time right so they're really
excited about using our integrated
platform to improve productivity in
their production line smart parking is
one another of our customer who are
using is an HTP you and also looking at
plot ith and overall platform to really
revolutionize the parking experience by
pushing intelligence to the edge with
with the entire platform so we pretty
excited with where we're headed with
overall our edge story and and and the
positive feedback from the customers is
really encouraging as well now we
understand that for for when we build a
platform and as we start offering our
edge solution we really have to work
with we really want to work with our
partners ecosystem so we've started
engaging with a couple of our
key partners for example force in
semiconductor companies such as arm nxp
are working with us to build the system
and module with HM as I showed in a
slide using the HTP you which which can
be used by other device makers we are
also working with some of our key
gateway device makers such as hitachi
ventura
hearting nokia next calm and act on who
are evaluating our platform to take
those HTP us sawn into their industrial
gateway so they can push the
intelligence to the edge and really
offer it to the customers and take it to
the market we're also working with some
of the edge computing companies such as
a d-link you know kelvin olya analytics
smart catch tracks who are building
smart solution using our cloud iot edge
software HTP you and the overall
integrated AI platform for for the edge
solution as well so we're working hard
on the partner ecosystem we're gonna
continue to work with a lot of more
partners and we're very excited with
with the partner response we have gotten
so far so as you can see just to sort of
summarize we are really working towards
an integrated AI solution so that with
our cloud IT platform what you heard
today is our edge offering so HTP you
chip which is our high performing
hardware chip for machine learning
inference on the device itself cloud iot
edge which is a software stack for
running machine learning in inference on
your edge device which you can run on HD
which is optimized for HTTP you and can
also work when the devices that doesn't
have HTTP you and this works seamlessly
with our clarity platform which includes
clarity chorus as a managed service pops
up cloud machine learning engine and
other services as well so we are very
excited with our what with our
integrated AI solution with for with
the platform and we can't wait we can't
wait to see where enterprise developers
and customers can build with with this
with this platform so next steps we are
we're offering early access to this is
an early access program with cloud ith
and HTTP you you can sign up for access
on on these sites you can either go to
cloud.google.com slash iot - edge or
cloud.google.com / h - TPU and our plan
is that we will initially give pride
access to select customers get their
feedback and then by fall we'll start
offering the HTTP you board to more more
broadly and to collect more feedback so
we can refine a platform and really make
it says that it's seamless and it's
integrated for for enterprise developers
and customers to build integrated ki
solution so with that I really want to
thank you all for coming over here we we
will be waiting here for a couple of
more minutes if you guys have questions
you can come to on the side of the stage
and ask us questions but really excited
with where we're heading and thank you
for your time
[Music]